twin motion renders are getting better
every single update
but with one click we can make them so
much better
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomach and welcome back to the channel
right now in 2021 i'm a registered
architect in the state of western
australia
and i've also been a photographer and
videographer for a very
very long time now so when it comes to
creating some absolutely beautiful
content and getting the right angles set
up in twin motion i know what i'm doing
here
what most people don't actually
understand when they see my renders and
when they see my work
is that the twin motion export isn't all
that's actually done
once it's exported from twin motion it
goes into lightroom
where it gets a few little tweaks here
and there to make them
absolutely perfect now i'm also going to
be giving away these presets to five
lucky winners so stay tuned to find out
how you
can win some of these presets to make
your twin motion renders
so much better okay so it all starts in
twin motion and it doesn't matter really
what project you're using
it just kind of matters what kind of
settings you've implemented in twin
motion
so i've got twin motion up on the screen
here and i'll share my screen
in this recording basically what you
need to do is
adjust your weather and time location to
be able to maximize these presets
they have been designed for the generic
summer look in twin motion and a few
clouds here and there
but then they're edited in the lightroom
to give you a full range of any season
for both
internal and external photos so with
twin motion open you want to move across
the little leaf on the left hand panel
and select weather the weather should be
about two of those dots in
to create some clouds into the sky you
can move a little bit further
to give it a bit more but don't go too
far where you start to see these puddles
on the ground because that turns in
to winter so if we move it back just
that tiny bit to get rid of those
puddles
somewhere about there is absolutely fine
as for the time settings we usually
adjust them
ever so slightly down to about
four or five o'clock depending on where
you are or either 6
7 a.m again depending on the location we
want it just after sunrise or just
before sunset
before it turns to that orange ambient
look
so the shadows aren't too harsh and the
natural light is at its best
when you've set that all up it's very
simple you just export whatever photo
you're looking at
and you get your generic exports so for
example i exported a couple images
just the other day which is of an
interior lounge room setting
there was a pool in the background lots
of greenery lots of different colors so
it made this
shot the perfect render to actually
showcase the ability of these presets
now i've created my own presets here
there is eight presets two for every
season
one for internal one for external so for
example there's a winter internal and a
winter external
if you wanna get a copy of them there's
a link down below where you can get your
copy
of these presets today there's also
installation instructions
if you're using a different version of
lightroom but i'm going to go through
installing these presets
on lightroom classic right now first
thing we're going to do is actually
import some photos
from the twin motion exports into
lightroom to be able to utilize these
presets
so we come over to library at the top
here move down to import
and find the photos you're looking to
import the easiest way for me personally
is to find them
and just drag and drop straight into
lightroom and that allows you
to quickly import them without having to
run through all your folders again
so if we import those photos you can see
that they're still pretty good but they
aren't the absolute best
they can be so we want to make them a
little bit better you want to head over
to the develop tab on the top
right hand side and open up the presets
panel
as you can see i have absolutely nothing
in my presets panel so we want to click
add a new preset
and import presets
once the little finder window comes open
you just navigate to where you
downloaded
those presets packs from my website and
you can directly import them
you find the first zip folder unzip that
then there'll be an additional zip
and installation instructions you want
to keep that secondary zip folder still
zipped so it can import all of those
imports at once so once we've downloaded
them you're going to be able to open up
the presets tab and
scroll down to the user presets the user
presets
is where you're going to find all the
installed presets from that zip folder
and like i already mentioned there's
multiples of each season
so if we were to take a look at let's
start with autumn for example
autumn interior if we add that preset it
automatically changes
everything to make it look like autumn
and it cleans up the internals it makes
them more bright
vibrant and a lot more professional and
realistic looking because this is
obviously an
internal render we want to stick to the
files labeled internal
because the lighting is obviously a
little bit different so for example if i
was
to move across to autumn external you'll
see how all the lighting and the colors
in the background
change and they no longer look like
autumn that's because
the lighting inside and outside for twin
motion exports is completely different
hence why i've split them up into two
different categories now one of my
favorite presets for this
photo in particular is actually my
internal winter
preset so if we move across to winter
internal you'll see how moody and dark
it gets as if it's cold and you want to
light up a fire and just
cuddle on that couch because it is now
nice and dark and moody
versus that autumn preset which was a
lot lighter a lot more vibrant
with the trees in the background being
more that fall colors
more oranges more yellows versus those
bright bright greens
now for absolute maximum contrast we're
going to move back to the winter
internal
preset and then jump to the summer
internal preset
so you can see that there is a huge
difference between these two presets we
go from really dark and moody
to really bright with that yellow
natural sunlight beaming through
and making that whole scene seem so much
more warm and inviting versus that
cold and dark winter feel now you've
made it this far in the video firstly
thank you so much for making it this far
and secondly i want to tell you guys how
you can win
all eight of these presets so i'm going
to be giving away five
sets of these presets to you guys to
enter it is very
very very simple all you have to do is
subscribe to this channel
and follow me on instagram i'm gonna
leave a link down in the description
below
one for these digital downloads and two
for all of you guys who are looking to
follow me on instagram to enter this
competition
like i said there is going to be five
winners absolutely anywhere in the world
it is a digital download it is
absolutely easy to install
as you've just seen and so useful for
all of your renders
if you're looking to get the best out of
your content make sure you check out the
digital downloads below
because there isn't anything else on the
market that i found specifically
designed for twin motion
to make your renders amazing anyway
that's all for me today guys thanks so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video
i hope you got some good knowledge out
of this and are going to be able to
create your twin motion renders
to the absolute best capabilities you
can if there's anything else i can help
you with please feel free to leave a
comment down below i do try to answer as
many people as i can
and because it is february we are doing
28 videos in
28 days so usually it would be c next
monday
but because it is february i will see
you tomorrow